veamos si observando la tabla periódica
podemos definir alguna regla o tendencia
general para los estados de oxidación
primero enfoquémonos en los metales
alcalinos todos los que están en esta
columna
bueno excepto el hidrógeno al rato lo
vemos es un caso especial por ahora solo
veamos a los metales alcalinos
son el grupo uno de los elementos
habíamos visto que estos elementos no
son muy electro negativos tienen un
electrón de valencia y no tienen
problema en donar ese electrón así que
su estado de oxidación no es una carga
supuesta son buenos candidatos para
formar en la sesión y cos y es muy común
que cuando estos elementos forman los
enlaces iónicos serán los elementos
oxidados cuestionan un electrón y
terminan con una carga 1 positiva si
ahora observamos el grupo que está junto
al de los metales alcalinos
todos estos elementos
tienen dos electrones de valencia y
tampoco son muy electro negativos
estos elementos podrán dar todos sus
electrones o sólo una parte de ellos
pero en el caso en que sólo puedan usar
el enlace iónico en ese negocio o se da
todo o se quita todo entonces el estado
de oxidación para estos elementos es de
más dos en una situación en la que
tuviéramos un enlace iónico estos
elementos donarán su par de electrones
porque no son muy electro negativos y
les falta mucho para completar los 8
electrones de valencia veamos ahora el
otro lado de la tabla periódica en el
grupo 7 tenemos a los halógenos los
halógenos al estar del lado derecho de
la tabla periódica son muy electro
negativos
les falta un electrón para estar
completos desde el punto de vista de
electrones de valencia así que estos
elementos son usualmente reducidos
tienen un estado de oxidación de menos 1
y digo usualmente porque no siempre es
el caso pueden ocurrir otras cosas pero
se sabe que estos elementos quieren
ganar un electrón si observamos ahora el
grupo de la izquierda aquí tenemos al
grupo 6
en este grupo tenemos al oxígeno ya
habíamos dicho que oxidar tiene que ver
con algo que el oxígeno hace es decir
quedarse con electrones de otro elemento
así que estos elementos son los que
oxidan el oxígeno es un buen agente
oxidante otra forma de pensar lo es que
el oxígeno se lleva electrones le gusta
llevarse los electrones entonces su
estado de oxidación es normalmente de
menos 2 o también su carga se reduce por
2 electrones generalmente estos son los
elementos reducidos y estos son los
elementos oxidados y podemos seguir
ahora con los elementos del grupo 5 su
estado de oxidación más común es de
menos 3 y ahora empezamos a observar una
tendencia general la tendencia no es una
regla
entre más y más nos acerquemos a la
mitad de la tabla periódica habrá más
variación en los estados de oxidación es
dejado al hidrógeno aparte porque si
realmente lo pensamos el hidrógeno sólo
tiene un electrón tal vez puedan pensar
bueno donará su electrón y se quedará
con cero electrones pero también
podríamos ver al hidrógeno como un
halógeno lo podemos ver actuando como un
metal alcalino pero en teoría su lugar
en la tabla periódica también podría
estar aquí porque para que el hidrógeno
pueda tener completa su capa electrónica
solo necesita un electrón por eso podría
estar también por aquí y entonces puede
tener un estado de oxidación uno
positivo o negativo veamos un ejemplo de
esto pensemos en la situación en donde
el hidrógeno actúa como agente oxidante
un ejemplo de eso
ese litro de litio
en el hidruro de litio el hidrógeno es
más electro negativo que el litio el
litio dona su electrón y así el
hidrógeno oxida al litio y el litio
reduce al hidrógeno el hidrógeno acapara
los electrones y el estado de oxidación
del litio termina siendo de 1 positivo y
el estado de oxidación del hidrógeno es
1 negativo una vez más solo para que
quede claro el litio ha sido oxidado por
el hidrógeno y el hidrógeno ha sido
reducido por el litio
ahora veamos un ejemplo en donde el
hidrógeno actúa al revés
ahora tenemos hidróxido de lannion
hidróxido aquí tenemos un hidrógeno y un
oxígeno podemos pensar que una molécula
de agua perdió un protón de hidrógeno
pero se quedó con su electrón tiene una
carga negativa este año tiene una carga
formal 1 negativa y qué está pasando
aquí déjenme dibujar esto porque es
realmente divertido aquí tenemos una
situación en la que el oxígeno tiene 1 2
456 electrones cuando tenemos la
molécula de agua y tenemos dos
hidrógenos y comparten aquí tenemos un
enlace covalente porque se comparte un
par de electrones por acá tenemos otro
para llegar al hidróxido el oxígeno se
queda con este par de electrones y ahora
lo pondré en otro color
ahora el oxígeno tiene este par de
electrones y un enlace covalente con el
otro hidrógeno este hidrógeno que
teníamos aquí termina siendo un protón y
ahora toda esta molécula tiene una carga
negativa así nos queda el hidróxido
sabemos que el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno así que
acapara a los electrones y le dirá al
hidrógeno mira hidrógeno si nos obligan
a tener un enlace iónico perderás todos
tus electrones
recuerden que el estado de oxidación es
sólo una herramienta que nos sirve
cuando tenemos que pretender que no hay
enlaces covalentes sino iónicos así que
cuando el hidrógeno pierde su electrón
termina con un estado de oxidación más
uno
es oxidado por el oxígeno y el oxígeno
ganó un electrón si tuviéramos que
pensar en esta molécula con enlaces
iónicos diríamos que el oxígeno ganó dos
electrones entonces tiene un estado de
oxidación de 2 - recuerden que cuando
escribimos los estados de oxidación y
las cargas iónicas como super índice el
signo se escribe después del número así
se acostumbra
ahora que ya vimos dos ejemplos el punto
era mostrarles que el hidrógeno puede
tener un estado de oxidación uno
positivo o uno negativo observen que los
estados de oxidación de estas moléculas
le dan a toda la molécula una carga
total si tenemos una carga 1 positiva y
1 negativa entonces nos queda 0 lo cual
es lógico porque la molécula de hidruro
de litio es neutral no tiene carga y por
acá el hidrógeno tiene un estado de
oxidación de uno más y el oxígeno tiene
un estado de oxidación de 2 - si sumamos
ambos estados nos queda una carga total
1 negativa que es exactamente la carga
de la unión
hidróxido